tenemos una función vectorial r que
depende de dos parámetros digamos aceite
y que es igual a una función x que
depende de aceite que multiplica el
vector unitario en la dirección del eje
x más una función que depende de aceite
y que multiplica nuestro vector jota que
es el vector unitario en la dirección
del eje y y que le sumamos z de aceite
que multiplica el vector k que es el
vector unitario en la dirección z ahora
ya que tenemos esta función definamos o
pensemos que significa tomar la derivada
parcial de esta función vectorial con
respecto de uno de los parámetros s o te
creo que es muy natural no hay no hay
nada raro en esta definición ya hemos
tomado antes derivadas parciales de
funciones no vectoriales cuando sólo
cambia una de las variables verdad solo
la tomamos respecto de esa variable y la
otra la consideramos constante haremos
eso aquí así que vamos a hacer este
procedimiento simplemente
tomando la derivada parcial de cada uno
de los términos muy bien así que vamos a
definir la derivada parcial la derivada
parcial de r respecto de s lo vamos a
hacer con s después podemos cambiar el
papel de s por la t y si se obtiene el
mismo resultado así que lo definimos
como ya es usual con el límite cuando
delta s se aproxima a 0
de r d s + delta ese combate porque solo
buscamos este límite verdad tomamos la t
constante así que y bueno ahora que hay
que hacer ahora hay que restar r de st y
dividir todo esto entre delta s
todo sobre delta s muy bien muy bien
ahora con un poquito de álgebra aquí
podemos ver que r como función de ese
más delta ese combate me es esta función
y luego habría que restarle la función
era que ya habíamos definido pero rds
más delta ese son las componentes
evaluadas en ese más de alta ese así que
déjenme reescribir esto rápidamente esto
es el límite cuando delta s se aproxima
a 0 de primero las componentes en x x de
ese más delta ese combate menos x de ese
combate que restar la componente de rds
más delta ese combate le restamos x de
st que es la componente en x de r y eso
lo dividimos entre delta s y lo
multiplicamos por y ahora de forma
análoga escribimos ya que depende de ese
más delta s t
y le restamos le restamos de ese combate
y lo dividimos entre delta s
ahora finalmente hay que multiplicar por
el vector unitario j ahora ya nada más
nos falta la variable zeta que es zeta
bs + delta ese combate menos zeta de ese
combate y esto sobre delta s y ahora hay
que multiplicar por nuestro vector
unitario acá muy bien todo esto viene de
la definición del límite sí sí y además
de poner en vez de ese poner s más delta
s verdad y agrupamos en los términos que
requerimos con suerte a la vista salta
que esto es la derivada parcial de x
respecto de s verdad es la expresión de
la derivada parcial de x respecto de ese
como función o vectorial lo mismo para
la función ley para la función zeta son
las derivadas parciales de cada uno de
estos que esas ya las hemos visto
ahora esto por supuesto se convierte en
un vector porque estamos multiplicando
por los vectores unitarios verdad así
que esta es la definición de las
derivadas parciales comunes y corrientes
que ya hemos visto y donde se toma el
límite cuando delta s se aproxima a cero
ahora esto será igual o bueno ese es
exactamente el la derivada parcial de x
respecto de s por y más la derivada
parcial de y respecto de s por jota
y finalmente sumamos la derivada parcial
de z respecto de s por k así que
finalmente sólo resultó de derivar
respecto de s cada una de las entradas
ahora lo que voy a hacer aquí va a
resultar un poco raro es es para obtener
buenos elementos de las herramientas
para vídeos de integrales de superficie
así que lo que haré en adelante es algo
pseudo matemático porque realmente las
diferenciales son algo bien difícil de
definir rigurosamente pero nos da una
intuición de qué es lo que está pasando
así que esto de aquí esto que de esta
línea que estoy siguiendo no se
encuentra en libros de matemáticas
usuales en realidad si algún matemático
me ve haciendo esto bueno yo creo que me
puede pegar pero esto va a servir para
crear la intuición de lo que vamos a
hacer en la integral de superficie
ok todo esto que tenemos aquí es igual
lo voy a poner como r de ese más de ese
una diferencial de ese que es un cambio
muy pequeño en ese y le restamos r de
ese combate entre de ese que es insisto
un pan un cambio pequeños y mishima y sí
mismo de ese lo podemos escribir de este
modo así que tomando el límite cuando
delta s se aproxima a cero es como tomar
una una diferencial de s es decir un
cambio súper súper súper chiquitito
verdad así que por ejemplo cuando
alguien escribe la derivada de ella
respecto de xy digamos que esto fuera 2
y entonces como como si fueran números
multiplicamos por una de x de ambos
lados y entonces lo que resulta es que
vélez es igual a 2 de x verdad
lo que me imagino yo es como si fuera un
cambio infinitamente pequeño de y pues
resulta que es dos veces el cambio en x
verdad un cambio igualmente pequeño en x
y esto es bueno si si se tiene un cambio
súper pequeño de x el cambio de lleva a
ser siendo muy pequeño pero va a ser el
doble en general yo veo los
diferenciales como cambios muy pequeños
en una variable ahora dejando de esto a
un lado y al explicarte lo que lo que
haría enojar a muchos matemáticos por lo
que escribí espero que te dé un poco de
digo desde certeza de que no es una
locura que yo me inventé lo que quiero
decir es que si delta s se aproxima a
cero
podemos pensar a de s la diferencial de
s como un cambio infinitesimal muy
pequeño entonces ahora sí que sucede a
la izquierda lo que tenemos es la
derivada parcial de r respecto de ese
correcto
muy bien ahora esto lo voy a escribir en
rosado déjenme ponerlo como si
multiplicará por 10 y baja por la
diferencial de s
esto será igual bueno va a resultar
igual si multiplicamos del lado derecho
por de s esta cosa pues va a desaparecer
así que simplemente nos queda r&b s más
la diferencial de ese combate - r ese
combate
y vamos a encerrar esto en un recuadro
esto nos va a resultar muy valioso para
el próximo vídeo vamos a pensar en lo
que esto significa para visualizarlo en
una superficie como lo puedes pensar
esto de aquí es un vector tienes dos
funciones vectoriales y tomamos la resta
así que esto va a ser de gran ayuda para
el próximo video con las integrales de
superficie con el mismo razonamiento
podemos hacer lo mismo con t verdad
definimos la parcial dibujo voy a
hacerlo de forma pequeña la derivada
parcial respecto de t de r
ok mejor con otro color digamos naranja
la parcial de r respecto de t pues va a
ser igual al límite cuando del tate se
aproxima a 0 de lo mismo r s coma temas
del tate bueno lo mismo pero cambiando
el papel de ese conte menos rds combate
sobre del tate es decir dejamos fijo
ahora ese y lo que hacemos es un cambio
en t
muy bien dividimos entre delta t así que
esto es la derivada parcial de x
respecto de temas la parcial de ayer
respecto de temas la parcial de zeta
respecto de teito y todos ellos
multiplicando a sus vectores
correspondientes y con el mismo
argumento llegamos al mismo resultado
pero en términos de t así que si hacemos
las mismas pseudo matemáticas pues
obtendremos que la parcial de respecto
de t por de la diferencial de t será
igual donde insisto la diferencial de t
es un pequeñísimo cambio ente será rds
coma temas la diferencial de t - r de s
t muy bien así que marquemos estas dos
cosas en el próximo vídeo vamos a
visualizar lo que quiere decir cada uno
de ellos en ocasiones cuando hace un
poco de matemáticas tontas como estas
dice bueno y todo esto se vale no
olvides que estamos tomando derivadas
respecto a cada una de las variables
juguemos un poco con todo esto para ver
que estos dos nos van a resultar muy
valiosos para lograr intuición
se ven las integrales de superficie